There are many ways to complete a task---even
a seemingly simple one like eating cereal.
When programming a computer to complete a
task or solve a problem, repetitive techniques
like iteration and recursion are extremely
useful. In this video, we will look at these
problem-solving techniques.
This video is part of the Problem Solving
video series. Problem-solving skills, in combination
with an understanding of the natural and human-made
world, are critical to the design and optimization
of systems and processes.
Hi, my name is Niaja Farve. I am a doctoral
student in Electrical Engineering and Computer
Science at MIT.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with introductory programming and
simple data structures.
After watching this video, you will be able
to: Divide a programming problem into simpler,
analogous pieces. And, solve the problem by
combining solutions to the simpler pieces.
In computer science, we often want to solve
complex problems. However, computers deal
best with performing easy tasks over and over
again. We utilize the computer's ability by
implementing repetitive techniques to incrementally
solve our complex problems.
Though eating a bowl of cereal is a fairly
simple task that most of us can complete automatically,
we need to think carefully about how to program
a computer to do the same. Let's take a closer
look at the problem and identify the fundamental
steps used to frame cereal eating for repetitive
computation.
In this example, let's suppose the computer
understands the basic operation of eating
a single bite of cereal, but does not understand
how to eat an entire bowl of cereal. So how
do we "teach" the computer to eat a bowl of
any size greater than one bite? Pause the
video here and think about it.
The first step when approaching a complex
programming problem is to break the problem
up into analogous, but simpler pieces that
we can tell the computer how to directly solve.
So what is a simpler version of eating a whole
bowl of cereal?
One possibility is eating a smaller amount
of cereal.
We already mentioned that a small, non-zero
amount of cereal the computer can handle eating
is a single bite.
Going one step up, eating two bites-worth
of cereal is equivalent to eating a single
bite twice. The next step when approaching
a complex problem is to deduce a pattern.
That is, how does a generally larger problem
look in comparison to the simpler version?
Here, we notice that eating any amount of
cereal is equivalent to the sum of eating
multiple bites-worth of cereal.
Now that we've broken up our problem and understand
how the pieces will fit back together, we
can put our solution into a generalized code
framework:
Start with telling the computer the procedure
for solving the simplest problem. Then, repeat
this procedure on subsequent pieces until
the desired endpoint is reached:
If the bowl contains cereal, take one bite
of cereal. Repeat until there is no more cereal.
You may recognize this type of solution as
an iterative approach.
Or we could also take the following alternative
approach:
Start with telling the computer how to solve
the simplest problem. Then, break the problem
into simpler and simpler pieces until we reach
the version we've already told the computer
how to solve.
Does the bowl contain 1 bite of cereal? If
so, take the bite. If not, divide it up into
a bowl containing one bite and a bowl containing
the remainder. Repeat this procedure on the
resulting bowls.
In this case, we end, up with a series of
bowls containing one bite, which the computer
knows how to eat.
Breaking up a problem into progressively simpler,
but analogous pieces in this way is known
as a recursive approach. Because the solution
to the most complex problem depends on solutions
to the simpler pieces, recursion creates a
queue of jobs waiting to be completed.
In contrast, when using iteration, there is
no such dependency from one instance of the
problem to the next.
So even though the computer ends up consuming
n bites of cereal in both cases, the iterative
and recursive approaches arrive at this answer
in very different ways.
There are many different ways to successfully
eat a bowl of cereal or solve any given programming
problem. The key is to 1. Break the problem
into analogous pieces that the computer can
solve, and 2. Combine the solutions to the
pieces into a solution for the more complex
problem.
In our previous cereal-eating example, breaking
down the problem into simpler pieces was fairly
straightforward. Now, let's look at a slightly
more complex problem.
We would like to write a function, downup,
that takes an input string and prints out
progressively smaller and larger sub-strings
of the word as so.
To help us work with strings, we have a helper
function, substring, which extracts a portion
of a string, beginning from the first character
up though a specified end index.
Following the framework we discussed earlier,
what is a simpler version of downup that we
can easily handle?
How about downup of a single letter string.
The desired output is achieved by simply printing
the string.
Moving one step up, we see that the desired
output of a two-letter string can be accomplished
by printing the string, printing the string
shortened by one letter, and printing the
full string a second time.
And moving up one more step to a 3 letter
string...
Are you starting to notice any patterns? Pause
the video to think of a possibility.
Though there are many different patterns,
here is one you may have come up with: With
every string, we are sandwiching the _solution_
to a string one character shorter between
two printings of the full string. With this
mindset, we are poised for a recursive solution
to this problem.
Recall the general framework for a recursive
solution: Tell the computer how to solve the
simplest problem. Then break the problem into
simpler pieces until we reach the simplest
problem: If the string is a single letter,
print it. Otherwise, print the string, solve
for downup of the string one character shorter,
and print the string again.
Try now, if you haven't already done so, to
frame the problem in a more iterative manner.
Pause the video to discuss.
We can notice that we are repeatedly printing
substrings of the full string, with each step
moving the end index from the original length
down to 1. This is followed by again printing
substrings, but this time increasing the end
index back up to the original length.
We can program this solution using two iterative
loops. Recall the general iterative code framework:
Tell the computer the procedure for the simplest
problem. Repeat the procedure on subsequent
pieces until the endpoint is reached.
In our first loop, we print the substring,
decrease the index by one, and repeat the
procedure until the index reaches one.
In the second loop, we move in the opposite
direction. Print the substring. Increase the
index by one and repeat the procedure until
the index is greater than the original length.
Both approaches, while very different, are
completely valid! There is no one correct
way to solve a problem. Some solutions may
even have both recursive and iterative elements.
Now lets solve a third problem with an even
more complex pattern.
In the famous Towers of Hanoi problem, the
goal is to transfer a stack of rings from
pillar A to pillar C. We can only move a single
ring at a time, and can use pillar B as "extra"
workspace. We cannot place a larger ring on
top of a smaller ring.
Lets follow the framework and start by working
out the simplest problem: transferring 1 ring.
Here we can simply move the ring from A to
C.
Okay, now let's try to transfer a stack of
two rings. First we move the ring 1 to B,
then ring 2 to C, then move ring 1 from B
to C.
Now, let's try something a bit harder. Let's
try to transfer a stack of three rings. Ring
1 moves to C, ring 2 goes to B, and ring 1
goes to B. Now ring 3, which was on the bottom,
is free to move to C. Then, ring 1 goes to
A, ring 2 goes to C, then ring 1 finally goes
to C.
Notice that after we moved the bottom ring
to C, we essentially arrived at the same conformation
as when trying to transfer 2 rings: We have
two stacked rings and an extra empty pillar.
And because the largest ring is in the desired,
final position and does not impede the movements
of any of the remaining smaller rings, we
can treat the pillar as being empty.
This observation is crucial to the recursive
implementation of the towers of Hanoi solution.
We transferred n-1 rings to the extra pillar,
moved the largest ring to the final position,
then transferred the n-1 rings to the final
position.
Can you frame a pseudocode solution to the
problem? Pause the video here to work out
a possible solution.
Recall again the general recursive framework:
Tell the computer how to solve the simplest
problem: If we're transferring a single ring,
move it to the destination pillar.
Then, break the problem up into progressively
simpler pieces:
Transfer n-1 rings from the source to the
extra pillar, transfer ring n from the source
to the destination, and transfer n-1 rings
from the extra pillar to the destination.
Note that the source, destination, and extra
pillar designations change with each function
call!
It's always a good idea to check your code
with a test case. Pause the video here and
check your code for the case of N equals 4.
You may also wish to check our code and compare
the two solution methods.
Now lets check our code and traverse through
the solution for transferring 4 rings.
We're not transferring a single ring, so lets
transfer 3 rings from A to B.
We're still not transferring one ring, so
lets transfer 2 rings from A to C.
lets transfer 1 ring from A to B. And we can
finally move this single ring!
Now we return to the previous call, and can
move ring 2 from A to C. Then we transfer
our n-1 stack from B to C. This results in
transferring 2 rings from A to C!
Returning one more step back, we move ring
3 to B. Now we transfer 2 rings from C to
A.
Finally, we've returned back to our original
function call, and we've completed transferring
3 rings from A to B. So, we can move our largest
ring number 4 from A to C.
Now we need a whole other set of recursive
function calls to transfer the 3 ring stack
from B to C! Pause the video now to finish
checking the second half of our solution.
Notice how quickly the number of function
calls grew! Good thing we have a computer
that is very good at following repetitive
instructions!
To Review In this video, we showed you how
recursion and iteration take advantage of
a computer's ability to repeat simple tasks.
To approach a complicated programming problem,
first solve some simpler versions and try
to identify a pattern. Then, depending on
the type of pattern you found, fill in a recursive
or iterative code framework. And remember,
iterative, recursive and even mixed solutions
to a single problem may all be correct!